these pre-season videos hyping up shows
that i think my main audience which is
you would probably enjoy some are easy
picks for those lists while others i
judge based on the premise or what i
know of the source material now looking
back at this season though i realized
that there's been some really good stuff
that i missed out on when i went through
the seasonal list at first glance so
this is what this video is for now that
we have most of the season in the books
it's pretty interesting to go back and
look at the pre-season video to compare
the listed shows there have been some
big hits and some big misses for sure so
today we'll be going over what i think
ended up being the season's top 10 anime
i won't be including remakes or sequels
though so you won't be seeing stuff like
shaman king in there but before we begin
i'd like to encourage you to give the
video a like hit that subscribe button
and turn on your notifications so that
you can be first in the line next time i
upload a video done okay right let's get
on with the list we start off with
rom-com or samarkey
[Music]
admittedly this show is something that i
overlooked a bit during the preseason
however the voice actors got me
featuring some of my favorite names in
the industry who are ironically all
close friends who've worked together
immensely they've been through a lot
kind of like the characters in the
actual show with a title that outright
says the childhood friend won't lose the
show feels like some kind of self-aware
rom-com it ends up being some sort of
revenge story rom-com that i don't think
that we see that often the premise is
really good and i think that the
characters all have chemistry with one
another either because of the writing or
the execution since the voices behind
the characters have so much chemistry
already i really dig the cutesy art
style and the color palettes in this one
it's just perfect for a show like this
and i feel that it helped make the show
a lot more entertaining than it seemed
at first the show won't blow anyone's
minds but it's a decent pick up for the
season especially if you're one who
likes rom-coms
ninth on the list is combatants will be
dispatched
[Music]
okay so listen to this you've got an
obnoxious protagonist who looks like
he's had enough of life on an adventure
besides the straight-laced blonde girl
he's with our protagonist is joined by
an ambitious captain of the god a dark
mage and a chimera with genibio
tendencies if it sounds like some sort
of konosuba love child you're absolutely
correct as it's from the same creator
from an anecdotal standpoint it seems
that when it comes to fantasy the same
court of archetypes and personalities to
form that specific four or five person
party has proven to work excellently i
mean you do see shades of it in the core
cast of ari furetha princess connect has
something resembling it too they all
differ in execution and for combatants
who will be dispatched that comes in the
form of some tactical warfare gimmicks
and a heavy focus on lewd comedy if
you're up for something like gonosuba
and want more of the laughs and the
degeneracy from it combatants should be
part of your watch list no question
at number eight we take a look at
shadows house
shadow's house is an interesting show
before the season started i praised its
overall ambiance in its victorian era
backdrop i felt that we're due for
another creepy gothic anime and so far i
think that my expectations for shadow's
house have been met the mysteries are
great and i had my ample full of
suspense from this anime and while i
wouldn't put shadow's house as anime of
the season candidate i think the
cloverworks has done an overall
excellent job in bringing the series to
life seriously it just does such a good
job at captivating the audience with
those eerie supernatural elements in the
overall cinematography you get drawn
into the mystery of the shadow's house
and like a spectre the anime just
doesn't let you go once it's in your
grass i can't wait to see more with each
passing episode and as more questions
appear with everyone that gets answered
if you're like me and if you're looking
for something chilly and mysterious this
season has this great anime for you
[Music]
seventh in line is don't toy with me
miss nagatoro
[Music]
it's a show that i braced myself for
early on in the season but surprisingly
the reception towards nagatoro has been
pretty taped i admit that seeing
nakathora's smug face for the first few
episodes was quite addictive and i think
that in terms of the production side of
things the show is serviceable the
acting's great and i think that the art
is just right for a show like this i
can't help but feel sorry for the poor
guy though the show has been getting a
steady increase in his fan base through
the anime adaptation and i think that a
lot of it has to do with the characters
and their antics we've seen the bullying
turning into romance thing before still
i don't think that makes it a bad show
if you're looking for a rom-com with
that premise nagatoro should suffice in
giving you your fill for the season
number six on the list is higahiro
kajimoto
here's another winner that i admittedly
overlooked before the season started i
mean i figured that the premise might
not be everyone's cup of tea but after
watching the first few eps and reading
some of the source material i'd say that
higahiro is one of the best romances
that we have this season i'd also say
that you should give the show a chance
because when you do it does shine in a
lot of ways it seems the past few years
the parent-child dynamic in anime has
been gaining some momentum despite the
premise possibly setting off some red
flags i don't find anything too
questionable about the series yep
there's some minor fan service in there
but come on are we still piling about
fan service in anime in this day and age
especially when things like aeromanga
sensei exists and make whatever fan
service in higuer heroes seem like
child's play to be completely honest
higahiro is a very wholesome series
filled with dramatic moments about
relationships and taking
responsibilities higahiro reminds me of
those self-help shows like tomozaki or
origairu and if you want something like
that but with a parental relationship
element higahiro is the show for you
next in line is eden zero
for all the memes and jokes made about
mashima's character design decisions and
such eden zero has proved to be a pretty
cool show that deserves to be one of the
top anime of the season it's still early
but it's providing ample entertainment
for me especially as a fan of fairy tale
i'd have the fairytale comparisons to
end with that statement because i feel
that eden zero deserves to stand on its
own as a quirky fun adventure with how
hit or miss the studio's been the past
few years jc staff has done a pretty
good job adapting the series i didn't
notice some index tier rushing or one
punch man two-tier animation i'd say the
eden zero is not exactly the most unique
anime out there but it doesn't need to
be the tropes are there the usual mushy
my hero things are there the shonen
cliches are there but are they
automatically bad i'd say no especially
if you can put them on a light-hearted
and easy-going adventure like this one
eden zero knows what it is and it
instead focuses its efforts on giving
the fans of the genre exactly what they
want
from a personal perspective 86 is one of
my most anticipated shows before the
start of the season it felt like a
breath of fresh air for action like
novels casual watchers would probably be
hooked by mandatory waifu character lena
the edgy feel that the trailer exudes or
the mecca and military elements it
seemed to be a renaissance of the mecca
genre in the modern era does 86 manage
to revive mecca into the mainstream well
not really however what it does provide
is an excellent story that i feel
perfectly fits the current state of the
times i don't really want to go too
political but when looking at the
content of 86 it does have those
undertones hidden underneath the
gripping story of hardship and
perseverance it has a lot to do with the
status quo and the class differences
between citizens some racial conflict
and some surprisingly deep ideas about
military might and what at first glance
could look like a seasonal popcorn flick
that's not even mentioning an amazing
soundtrack presented by the legendary
hiroyuki sawano 86 is a winner for the
season you should definitely check it
out
when the season started i honestly
didn't know what to expect from vv it
looked appealing enough and i wanted to
watch sci-fi and it's done by the guys
who gave us re-zero but expectations
were rather tempered when i look back
well it turns out that what we have here
is a strong candidate for animate of the
season just like 86 before it i feel
that vivi has a bevy of strong themes
mostly to do with morals politics and
the fight against fate however we all
know casual watchers typically aren't
immediately drawn to a series through
those themes right so for that bb has
its spectacular visuals amazing
soundtrack and a fast-paced execution of
the story it's very eye-catching to say
the least even having one of my favorite
anime fights that feature female
characters and there's more on that on
the other video that i'll be linking
overall i'd say that this anime is
amazing if you like sci-fi animators
action-packed and way more than just
your usual popcorn flick give vivi a
shop i know you're going to enjoy it
number two for our list is to your
eternity
now here's a show that was a no-brainer
for inclusion to the preseason list it
seems that everyone's hyped for the show
and what do you know it didn't
disappoint one bit it's beautiful in so
many ways first is the art and the
presentation second is how immersive and
gripping of a journey is from start to
end it's one of those shows that i like
to call anime aspiring to become art
just like the feature-length films and
stuff like violet evergarden so your
eternity succeeds in following the
footsteps of those anime invoking strong
emotions and giving us an intricate look
at the human experience feelings like
joy pain sadness and all the other
things that make humanity what it is are
well presented in this title and it's a
show that takes you along for the roller
coaster of emotions now i wouldn't say
the show is flawless by the mere concept
of my belief that there's nothing
perfect however it does come very close
to being one of those cinematic anime
that people will eventually look back on
with high regard a unique premise done
well in such a beautiful way is a recipe
for anime of the season or even the year
candidate
however it somehow still doesn't make it
to the first place i feel that to your
eternity is super narrowly edged out by
my pick for this season
tokyo revenges
it raised stein's gate and re-zero fans
rejoice you found your successor in the
whole time travel genre and it ended up
being just as great as those titles
context considered prior to the season i
had high hopes for tokyo revenges there
we have it my top 10 picks for spring
2021 do you agree with my picks or not
share your thoughts in the comments
section if you ended up enjoying the
video and the recommendations you may
want to check out some perks that vinnie
tube offers i set some exclusive videos
for the channel that you can access
through channel memberships if you're up
for some specific titles such as re zero
or sword art online you can head over
and get some memberships for you and
your friends speaking of those titles
videos on those are also available on my
other channel vini tube kai it's a
channel that deals more with video
essays and analysis videos so if you
fancy that sort of content head on over
there through the link that i'll be
dropping that's it for today hope you
had fun until next time
you